Leon: So, welcome again, Volodya, to the American
Enterprise Institute, [Russian].
Vladimir: It's great to be here.
Thanks very much.
Leon: So, I hope to speak today, to cover
a lot of ground today, obviously what Putin's
doing inside Russia and outside Russia.
What do you and other pro-democracy activists
are doing in turn to oppose him and try to
build a democratic and free and prosperous
Russia.
Secondly, what can the United States do, especially
given that we're in the midst of our primaries?
And of course, we'll talk about Putin's foreign
policy, why he's doing what he's doing, and
where do you think he's going to stop, if
ever.
And finally, I hope, given that you're a Cambridge-trained
historian, to talk about the future of Russia
and the future of the regime, something that
you've written about a lot and thought about
over the years and, of course, have the first-hand
knowledge now.
I can't think of a single person who could
give us as good and in-depth a picture of
what's happening in Russia as you.
Vladimir: You're too kind, but I'll be happy
to try.
Leon: I'm sure we'll succeed.
So, the first question is a personal one actually,
personal to you, but I think it encapsulates
the nasty or probably bordering the bizarre
atmosphere now inside Russia.
Last week, the Chechen dictator, maybe soon
a caliph, Ramzan Kadyrov, posted a surveillance-like
video on his Instagram account where you and
another opposition leader Mikhail Kasyanov,
former Prime Minister, looked like being in
crosshairs.
Now, given that your friend and colleague,
Boris Nemtsov, was killed last year, and given
that you were nearly poisoned to death, or
so it seems, and that seems to be the consensus
now, that you were deliberately poisoned,
what do you think of this instance of harassment?
But maybe give us a broader sense as well.
Vladimir: Given Mr. Kadyrov's background and
reputation, both Mikhail Kasyanov and I consider
this video to be a direct threat, to be direct
and public incitement to murder, and in fact
we have already submitted an official request
for a criminal probe into this posting, this
publication.
In fact, in the last few weeks, we have seen
how serious of what seem to be coordinated
attacks and threats issued by Mr. Kadyrov
himself as well as his close henchmen against
Kremlin opponents, against Russian opposition
leaders.
And in fact, just a few days ago, Mr. Kasyanov
was physically attacked in Moscow by people
who looked like Chechens, and in fact there
were three serving members of the Russian
Interior Ministry in Chechnya who were briefly
detained after this.
And frankly, I think this whole series of
events is a direct result of the brazen impunity
that has surrounded the assassination of our
friend, my friend, Russian opposition leader
Boris Nemtsov, who was gunned down 200 yards
away from the Kremlin nearly a year ago in
February 2015.
Despite the fact that traces of this crime
evidently lead to Grozny or at least through
Grozny...
Leon: The capital of Chechnya.
Vladimir: Absolutely.
Or at least through the capital of Chechnya.
And despite the fact that those arrested on
suspicion of murdering Boris were serving
members of the Interior Ministry of the Russian
Federation in Chechnya.
Leon: Victorian Guard, I would think.
Vladimir: Absolutely.
Despite the fact that Mr. Kadyrov publicly
called the man accused of killing Boris Nemtsov
to be called a true patriot, and despite the
numerous requests by the lawyers representing
Boris Nemtsov's children to question Mr. Kadyrov
regarding this case, he wasn't questioned
even formally by the investigators.
We hear no criticism of him or his actions
or his public threats from the Kremlin, in
fact we hear the opposite.
We hear, we continue to hear laudatory statements
from the top Russian leadership with regard
to Mr. Kadyrov.
Just a few days ago, Vladimir Putin publicly
thanked Mr. Kadyrov for his effective work,
this is a quote.
And Kremlin Chief of Staff Sergei Ivanov said
on record that the Russian leadership has
no questions for Mr. Kadyrov.
Well, I think after such statements and after
such words, there are no questions left for
the Russian leadership itself.
But on the substance of your question, yes,
we know that it's a dangerous location to
be in opposition to Vladimir Putin's regime.
We have seen too many confirmations of that
already.
So we know the risks, we understand the risks.
But frankly I think, we, those who view the
future of Russia differently from what the
present regime does, we have no right to stand
down or to give up or to run away because
it's our country and we have to fight for
it.
Leon: Well, let's talk about this fight.
Last fall, Russia held local elections.
And your party, the party of People's Freedom,
known also as Parnas, was the only one that
was allowed to participate, and then only
in one out of 85 Russian regions.
I mean, clearly as you gear up, and that's
the essence of your work as I understand it
now, in Russia, as you gear up for the National
Parliament, Duma elections, this September,
this coming September, given this past record,
and given the record of the past, God knows,
10, 15 years, where is the hope?
Does it all seem hopeless and yet you continue
your work?
Vladimir: Well, first of all, let's just get
one thing clear.
There hasn't been a free and fair election
in Russia in at least 16 years.
If we judge by the statements and evaluations
of international monitors, namely from the
OSCE and from the Council of Europe, the last
election in Russia that corresponded at least
partially through the European standards of
free and fair elections were held in March
of 2000, so that's 16 years ago.
Every election since then has been characterized
by suppression of the opposition or outright
disqualification of the opposition, as you
mentioned.
And in these regional elections, for instance
last year, the People's Freedom Party was
prevented from participating in the elections
in Novosibirsk, in Kaluga, in Magadan, initially
in Novgorod.
And this is the usual picture.
You have to understand that as a rule, genuine,
real opposition to the Kremlin is not even
allowed to formally participate in the election
process, and we're off the ballot ahead of
time.
In those few instances when the opposition
is allowed to be on the ballot, we scored
pretty good results such as when Boris Nemtsov
won his legislative seat in Yaroslavl in 2013
when Alexei Navalny received, even according
to official results, nearly 30% of the vote
in Moscow in the mayoral election in 2013.
So, basically elections in Putin's Russia
has been turned into a meaningless ritual
to formalize the regime and to continue its
stay in power.
However, we believe, and I believe, and this
is also from historical experience, that boycotts
and passive posture never work.
And I think we have to use, even this bogus
and sham and watered-down election process,
as it exists today, in order to try to get
our message across to as many of our compatriots
as we can, and also to help young up and coming
political opposition, civil society activists
to gain some political experience by participating
in these campaigns, to gain some reputation,
to gain name recognition.
And this is precisely what we plan to do this
year, this September, on September 18th, when
Russia will hold the National Parliamentary
elections, or so-called elections, but nevertheless.
So, for instance, the Open Russia Movement,
of which I'm the national coordinator, has
tried twice already last year.
First on the municipal level in St. Petersburg,
and then on the regional level in Novosibirsk
to support candidates.
In both times, candidates whom we supported,
even again according to the official results,
came in second place with more than 20% of
the vote.
This is a really far cry from the 1.5% or
2% for the opposition and the Kremlin would
like people to believe.
So this year we're preparing to support 10,
15, maybe 20 candidates for the State Duma
in single-member districts across Russia,
mostly in big cities of course, but still
across Russia, we're not talking about just
Moscow, in order again to get our message
across, this pro-democracy, pro-European alternative
message to what the Kremlin is offering to
as many people as we can, and to help our
supporters, young opposition and civil society
activists, to gain this experience.
Because nothing is forever and this regime
is not forever, and there will come a time
when new generation of pro-democracy Russians
will have to take responsibility for the country
and we want to start getting them ready for
that today.
Leon: Excellent.
We will talk about Russia's future very soon.
But let me go back to, as announced, to foreign
policy.
Now, the word that's most commonly used, in
fact, we could count the number of times when
this word was used or has been used by the
Obama administration, high officials, state
department, White House, White House spokesman,
in reaction to Putin's foreign policy, and
that word is "surprised."
They're constantly surprised.
I mean, literally they're surprised.
I could say some of them are saying, I'm quoting
the spokesman for the White House, "Mr. Putin's
intentions are hard to discern," or, this
is my favorite, "We're dying to know what
Mr. Putin is doing."
Are you surprised by what he is doing?
And if not, why not?
Vladimir: Well, frankly, speaking for me personally,
I understood everything they needed to understand
about Mr. Putin.
And I even remember the date, it was the 20th
of December 1999 when he was still prime minister,
11 days from being acting president.
On that day, this was the day of the Chekist,
the day of the KGB or NKVD.
On that day, he did three things.
He opened a memorial plaque to Yuri Andropov
on Lubyanka Square on the KGB building.
Leon: Right, the former head of the KGB.
Vladimir: This is, of course, the notorious
head of the KGB who was instrumental in the
campaign against dissenters, who invented
this punitive psychiatry and actively promoted
it and so forth.
On the same day, he spoke at a big gathering
of KGB veterans and he told them that a group
of KGB employees that has been sent undercover
into the Russian government has fulfilled
their mission.
Everybody thought it was a joke at the time,
but he wasn't joking.
And the third thing he did on the same day
was to raise a glass to Joseph Stalin, because
this is also Stalin's birthday, the 20th of
December...
Leon: Ah, that's right, of course.
Vladimir: ... when he was meeting party leaders
in the Moscow White House.
So, for me, everything that needed to be understood
about Mr. Putin, I understood on that day.
Other people understood it even much earlier,
so I can't claim to be an oracle or anything
like that on this.
But I think everything he's now doing, in
terms of aggression outside of the Russian
borders, in terms of his foreign policy, is
direct consequences of what he's been doing
domestically since the very first days after
he came to power.
There is no reason, in my mind, to expect
a regime that tramples on the rights of its
own citizens and that disregards its own constitution
to, for some reason, respect the rights of
its neighboring countries and to respect international
law.
There's no reason to expect that.
I think one comes directly from another.
And many of us in the Russian opposition have
said this for a long time.
Unfortunately, not a lot of people among Western
elites chose to hear it.
And I think frankly if the leaders of Western
democracy has taken a firmer and more principled
stand against the Putin regime earlier on,
we would not be seeing the excesses we're
seeing today.
But we are where we are, and better late than
never.
And I hope that at least now the leaders of
the democratic nations of the West know, "Who
is Mr. Putin?"
A famous question that was posed in Davos
16 years ago now.
Just think about that number.
It's almost a full generation that's passed
in Russia since Mr. Putin came to power.
He's now been in power almost as long as Brezhnev
has, just two years away from that number.
Leon: Yeah, he's about to start competing
with Stalin if you count Stalin's single-man
dictatorship, full dictator, since about 1929
then to '53, that's 24 years.
Vladimir: Yes.
Leon: He's been in a striking distance.
Vladimir: Well, I'm certain he's not going
to get to that, but it's certainly coming
close.
You're right.
Leon: Just to close up on this, Syria, everybody
is concerned about Syria.
Again, every time Russia does something, every
time they bring more troops, every time they
move, they establish yet another base, this
time a stone's throw from Turkish border,
a NATO member, the official Washington is
surprised.
Surprised, surprised, surprised.
What's the endgame there in Syria?
Vladimir: Well, I think as with all of the
foreign policy adventures of this current
regime, the origins are domestic and are found
inside.
And once Eastern Ukraine, the Donbass became
a quagmire for the regime, once Ukraine proved
a too difficult target, and the so-called
Novorossiya Project clearly failed, the Kremlin's
propaganda machine needed new ammunition,
a new fodder to maintain, to revive rather,
the fate of the strongman image, to show another
round of television pictures purporting to
be a great power, to be sending troops halfway
across the world in an instant, to be an equal
in the world stage, if you will.
And this is when Syria came in.
And if you look at the Kremlin-controlled
television channels in Russia, which is of
course all the major television channels in
Russia today, you will see that Syria has
replaced Ukraine as the main subject.
Whereas before, they used to show all the
time the Donbass and the fight against the
so-called fascists and Banderavites in the
Donbass, now they're sharing Syria and the
so-called fight against terrorism that Putin
is, therefore, conducting in Syria.
Others, of course, in additional very important
reason, I think that the Kremlin is doing
this, the informal club of dictators is a
pretty loyal one, and Mr. Putin doesn't like
to see a fellow despot fall from power.
He's already seen too many in his time, from
Gaddafi to Yanukovych.
And I think an additional goal in this is
to help preserve Bashar al-Assad in power
in Syria and, of course, it's evident now
to everybody that the chief targets of the
Russian Air Force in Syria are not in fact
ISIS strongholds, but are the anti-Assad opposition
forces.
Leon: Well, back to the United States.
The presidential primaries are under way,
and unlike Russians, we don't know who will
be the president.
Now, what would be your advice to the presidential
hopefuls?
Vladimir: Well, I think, first of all, it's
important to state that it is our job and
our task to bring political changes in Russia,
to bring a democratic future for Russia.
This is a task for us, the Russian opposition,
not for anybody from the outside.
But I think the best thing the U.S. government
and the future U.S. president, whoever he
or she might be, can do with regard to Russia
is, frankly, to stand on the position of principle
and to make sure that relationship with the
Kremlin and with Russia is informed, above
all, by the values, the fundamental values
that form the basis of what the United States
is all about.
There's, unfortunately, too often being two
extremes in the way the U.S. government deals
with Russia and the Kremlin.
One extreme has been to blame the entire Russian
nation and Russia as a country for the actions
of the unelected regime that we have now.
And the other extreme is to befriend the Kremlin
dictator and to pretend that Putin is a fully
fledged friend and partner.
Unfortunately, we've seen wherein houses of
both parties fall into this trap in recent
years.
So I think it's very important on the one
hand to distinguish clearly and publicly between
Russia, on the one hand, and the Kremlin regime,
on the other hand, to recognize that Russia
today is ruled by an unaccountable, unelected
authoritarian regime, to maintain lines of
communications with Russian society and with
pro-democracy forces inside Russian society.
And to make it clear, and this is very important,
that a future democratic Russia will have
its rightful place at the table in the future
world.
That is a very important issue.
But on the other hand, when we're talking
about relationship with the current regime,
with Mr. Putin's regime in the Kremlin, I
think it's very important to approach them
from a position of principle and from a position
of strength, because a very important thing
to understand about the current regime is
that it does not consider compromise and accommodation
as an invitation to reciprocate.
It considers them as a sign of weakness, and
it becomes more aggressive and more brazen.
And again, we already talked about how they
have become more aggressive against Western
inaction and Western refusal to recognize
the reality in many cases.
And I think the most important thing is to
practice what you preach and to practice the
principles that you preach.
And I'd like mention one thing in particular.
A little more than three years ago, the U.S.
Congress passed the Sergei Magnitsky Rule
of Law Accountability Act, in my view, one
of the most principled pieces of legislation
ever passed in any parliament in the world.
This law, as you know, is designed to end
the impunity for those Kremlin officials and
Kremlin-connected oligarchs who continue to
abuse the rights of Russian citizens, and
to plunder resources of Russian taxpayers
by denying them the privilege, and it is a
privilege not a right, of traveling to and
keeping their assets in the United States.
This is a very pro-Russian law.
It's seen as a pro-Russian law by Russian
citizens, and there had been numerous opinion
polls to this effect.
Despite the Kremlin propaganda, the Kremlin
hasn't managed to present it as "sanctions
against Russia" because the Russian people
understand that these are targeted individual
personal sanctions against those who abuse
their rights and steal their money.
But, frankly, in the more than three years
since this law has come into effect, implementation
has been very timid, and we have seen only
low-level abusers targeted so far.
And I think it's important to not have any
glass ceilings with regard to this law, and
to include prominent human rights abusers
as well as low-level targets.
However many similarities there are between
the current regime and the Kremlin and the
Soviet regime, and there are many similarities
– we have political prisoners, we have media
censorship, we have elections without choice
as it were, and many, many other things that
are similar – there is one major difference,
and that is that while they put dissenters
in prison, and while they ruled through oppression
and coercion, the likes of Brezhnev, Suslov
and Andropov did not keep their bank accounts
in the West, they did not buy properties and
yachts in the West, they did not send their
kids to study in the West.
People from the current regime like to do
all that.
They like to rule inside Russia in a manner
of a third world dictatorship, but they like
to use all the privileges that the Western
democratic world has to offer for themselves.
Now I think this double standard must end,
and the best way for a future U.S. president,
whoever he or she might be, to show solidarity
with those people in Russia who strive for
a democratic future is to end this double
standard, and to make sure this law is implemented
to its full extent.
Leon: Let's talk about the Russian future.
Again, you're a Cambridge-trained historian
and you wear, among many hats that you wear,
I've always enjoyed your analytical articles,
and I've always enjoyed your work on Russian
history, and I'll mention one of them in a
moment.
The future of Russia and the future of the
regime, fortunately they're not synonymous,
and you're absolutely correct about this.
So let's start with something that has almost
become a cliche.
But like any cliche, I think it has a great
deal of truth to it, which is that there has
been an implicit social contract.
After the turmoil and the revolution and the
usual dislocation caused by great revolutions,
the institutions that were put and planted
in the 1990s, which are described as horrible
times, and times of lawlessness, and especially
corruption, that's particularly funny, the
growth started and, of course, this regime
benefitted hugely.
And the idea was that the people who were
first impoverished by the Soviet regime and
then gone through the traditional, normal
unfortunately, dislocation on the great revolution,
the regime offered a bargain, "You stay out
of politics and we see to it that your incomes
grow, there's stability, and there's certain
semblance of at least personal security."
And because at the beginning of Putin's rule,
oil was $18 a barrel, and then it went all
the way to $140 a barrel almost steadily,
with some hiccups, pretty much that contract
has been implemented.
Now, this contract appears to be under threat
now.
The economy contracted by 4%.
It is likely to contract 1%, 2%, 3%, 4% if
the oil stays at this level.
More importantly, as Putin's own advisors,
including his top advisor, Alexei Kudrin,
Former Deputy Prime Minister and Minister
of Finance, said on numerous occasions, many
times, Russia hid an institutional wall, the
institutions are so disfigured and so hostile
to the investment climate that even if, and
that's Kudrin's opinion, even if oil is back
to $100 a barrel, there's really no substantial
growth to Russia unless oil, as you put it,
grows $10-$14 a barrel every year, which is
very unlikely.
So let's start with this contract, between
the people and the regime.
It's under threat.
So could you describe what might be...and
I also should mention that the inflation,
of course, is 13%-14%.
Real incomes for the first time since Putin
has been in power, as you mentioned, 16 years,
are down by about 9%.
And of course, Putin imposed sanctions on
the imports in a country where because of
the regime's economic strategy has become
essentially a...or has instituted a bargain
whereby it sells oil and buys pretty everything
else with the petrol dollars, these sanctions
on food and even more importantly, for example
on medicine, are hurting a lot of people.
And the government is also slashing education,
they're slashing funds for medical care, social
mobility is virtually stopped, we know all
those things.
I don't want to go down the list.
So let's first discuss what do you think the
reaction of the people will be?
And also, what do you think the regime will
do to survive?
Vladimir: Well, I think two things are certain.
First of all, there was indeed such an implicit
social contract, as you mentioned.
And secondly that it is under severe threat,
and the Kremlin is increasingly struggling
to fulfill its end of that social contract.
The economic situation in our country today
is indeed in free fall.
Leon: Tell us what you see when you travel,
especially in provinces.
I understand the situation is getting to be
quite dire.
Vladimir: Sure.
Well, even if you look at all the major indicators,
even at the surface, we see a double-digit
inflation, we see a massive devaluation of
the national currency, more than 100% since
2014.
Leon: Correct.
Vladimir: We're seeing a decline in the GDP.
We're seeing a decline and a fall in real
incomes to the level of more than a decade
ago.
And sure, this is caused, to a major extent,
by falling oil prices, but here it also has
to be mentioned that during his rule, Putin
has actually increased the dependence of the
Russian economy on oil prices.
Oil and gas accounted for 40% of Russian exports
when Putin came to power.
Today it accounts for 70% of Russian exports.
And also it's the actions of the regime such
as the so-called counter sanctions that you
mentioned also that hit Russian consumers
much harder than they did the intended recipients.
But also the sanctions themselves that have
been caused by flagrant violations of international
law, which was also what the Kremlin regime
did.
Nobody forced them to it.
They chose to do it and these are the consequences.
So we're seeing a major, obviously, deterioration
of the economy.
And also, for example, going back to the oil
prices, today it's about $30 a barrel and
we're seeing 4%-5% decline in GDP.
When Mikhail Kasyanov, for instance, was Prime
Minister, the oil price was about $20-$25
a barrel and we saw 7%-8% growth over the
years.
So it's not, again, we can't blame everything,
or the Kremlin rather, cannot blame everything
on just the oil prices.
It's also the mismanagement.
It's also the destruction of institutions.
It's also the enormous level of corruption,
official corruption that, I think, it's safe
to say is now at the highest level it's ever
been in Russian history.
Leon: I apologize, Volodya, I'll let you continue,
but I just remembered something.
I was on a panel with Boris Nemtsov on the
80th anniversary of Boris Yeltsin's...
Vladimir: Five years ago.
Leon: Five years ago.
And of course, you know, there was a very
special relationship between the two.
First of all, they're both Borises and, secondly,
my sense is, from what I read as I wrote my
biography of Yeltsin and also from what I
heard from Boris Nemtsov, among others, Yeltsin
really treated him as a son that he never
had.
Vladimir: And he groomed him as a successor,
there's no doubt about it.
Leon: And groomed him as a successor, that's
correct.
So we were on the same panel together, and
Boris was always extremely funny and lighthearted
about things.
And one of the things he mentioned that I
want to say it now because of something that
you said, he said, "During most of Yeltsin's
rule, the price of oil on average was $18
a barrel.
How many days will Vladimir Putin survive
as a ruler or as the ruler of Russia if oil
were $18 a barrel?"
And then he said something that was very typical
of him, he said, "He would be carried on pitchforks
on the third day out of his Kremlin office."
I just thought I would remember Boris, and
I thought it was a fairly realistic assessment.
Vladimir: Sure.
And of course, Boris also was reminded that
in the summer of '98, during the financial
crisis, the price of oil, I believe, was between
$6 and $9 a barrel.
And again, today that government can only
dream of the level that Putin currently has
–
$30.
And we all the problems and all the crises
that are happening before our eyes in Russia
today under the management, or mismanagement
I should say, of Putin's regime.
So it's certain, I think, that the Kremlin
is increasingly struggling to fulfill its
part of the social contract in economic terms.
So in order to maintain its grip on power,
they're increasingly turning to repression
and to a relentless propaganda, finding the
external enemies, rallying up against them,
all these usual things, all these usual tricks
that are not new.
Leon: Right.
Vladimir: And we, as historians, we both saw
many, many examples of this in history.
But we also saw that these tricks and these
attempts to hold onto power usually end the
same way, and I think a very good parallel
would be what happened in our own country
in Russia in the late 1980s, early 1990s when,
as you remember, the political control of
the communist establishment remained in place,
the propaganda machine over the television
remained in place, but it simply became less
and less and less effective as the economic
reality increasingly diverged from the propaganda
image.
This is the proverbial battle between the
television set and the fridge.
And the fridge always wins.
Certainly in Russia, always wins.
And I think however much the current regime
will try to cling to its power, again by finding
enemies, by rallying up its propaganda machine,
by increasing repression and tightening the
screws, as it were, I think the end result
will be the same.
Unfortunately, and this is a very big problem,
and the Kremlin likes to accuse us, members
of the Russian opposition, of being revolutionaries
and preparing for a Russian Maidan.
Of course, I would say that the biggest revolutionaries
of all are the people in the Kremlin itself
today, because they're the ones who destroyed
all the institutions of the state, who turned
the elections into a meaningless farce, who
turned parliament into not a place for discussion,
as they themselves famously said, who turned
all the major media outlets into weapons of
its propaganda machine, and thus destroyed
and eliminated every single legal and constitutional
way of changing the government.
And in doing so, they ensured that whenever
change does come to Russia, political change,
and nothing is forever, and nothing is permanent,
that this change will take the shape of some
kind of a revolutionary process.
As the Kremlin themselves, as Vladimir Putin
himself, will ensure that this will be the
case.
And I'm not saying it with any pleasure because
as a historian, as you said, which I don't
think that revolutions are necessarily a force
for good, especially in our own Russian history,
but this is what the Kremlin's actions are
leading to, that whenever change does come
to our country, and again it will come, nothing
is forever, it will come as some kind of a
revolutionary form.
Leon: This is a good way, an excellent way
I should say, to lead to the next topic of
our discussion, which is the future of Russia.
In a broader sense, Vladimir, I think it would
not be an exaggeration to say that because
of this relentless assault on what we consider
normal civilized values – human rights,
human dignity, freedom of the press, honest
courts, and so and so forth – the regime
has managed to create probably the most cynical
society in Russian history, the most cynical
and the most corrupt, which, again as historians,
it's a hard first to take, as they would say
in Cambridge.
There's a great deal of competition in Russian
history.
But again, I'm throwing that in to see what
you think.
But as you mentioned, and again the public
opinion polls are all showing us, and I'm
drawing here on a very recent annual conference
of the Levada-Center, which is perhaps the
only reliable public opinion poll and independent
public opinion poll and firm in Russia.
And our colleague and friend, Lev Gudkov,
who is the chairman, said that there's been
the steady discreditation of the values of
democracy, human rights and lawful state.
And the result was what might be called the
morally scorched Earth.
In other words, the chilling picture of Russia
that we saw, for example, in this brilliant
movie, "Leviathan" which was nominated and
should've gotten an Oscar for the Best Foreign
Film, whereby so long as you pay to the next
level or you contribute to the next level,
essentially the coterie of the procurator,
the mayor, the chief of police, and the judge
could pretty much do whatever they want in
their own locale.
Now, how is it that given that this has been
going on for so long, how is that you hope
that you could draw on some sort of social
capital?
And let's not forget the immigration of the
best and the brightest.
The numbers are staggering, 200,000 in the
last few years according to the official data.
And it's just the entrepreneurs, the people
who would've invented things for Russia, the
people who would've opened new businesses
for Russia and created workplaces and jobs,
and simply the people who would've enriched
the Russian culture.
All of that has been draining hugely, not
to mention the flight of the investment capital.
And yet you continue to believe that you could
draw on something to create the Russia that
we talked about – free and prosperous.
Could you explain why you remain hopeful?
Vladimir: Well, Vladimir Bukovsky who's a
legendary figure, as you know, in the Russian
human rights movement...
Leon: The Soviet dissident.
Vladimir: Yes, and to this day, in fact.
And he once said the phrase that I always
like to remember, he said that, "One of the
most surprising things about Russia is that
at any time, despite everything, whatever
happens, there are always people in Russia
who are prepare to stand up to the lies, to
the injustice, to the repression, and defend
the honor and the dignity."
And if you look at the Soviet period, millions
of people were killed in the Gulag system,
millions more were broken in the same system
of prisons and labor camps, yet millions more
immigrated, left the country.
And yet in the late 1980s, early 1990s, the
Russian society found to strengthen itself
still to stand up and defend its newly-found
freedom and to prevent a return to totalitarianism.
And I think that's a very important lesson.
And it's absolutely true and it's pointless
to argue with it that Putin's rule in the
last 16 years has been maintained, not just
by economic giveaways, not just by coercion,
but also by a relentless propaganda that's
been fostering and emphasizing imperial complexes,
mistrust, aggression, finding so-called external
enemies.
Leon: And internal.
Vladimir: Yes, exactly, and internal.
And dividing people into us versus them, and
so on and so forth.
And this will be, I think, a horrible legacy
of the Putin regime, and it'll be one of the
most formidable tasks in my view of a future
post-Putin government in Russia to try to
undo the damage done by this propaganda to
the fabric of Russian society.
But just as always, just as before, there
are many people in Russia today, millions
of them, who see a different future for our
country, a future based on the rule of law,
based on political freedoms, based on the
dignity of the human being, based on European
what we call modern European values.
There are millions of them.
I see them and I meet them as I travel around
our country, and into different regions of
Russia.
They are not being heard under the current
regime.
They have no political representation.
They have no political voice.
It's designed to be that way under the present
regime.
But these people are there.
They exist.
And in my view, they offer the best hope for
Russia's future development.
Leon: Volodya, again, you touched on this
here and there, but for better or worse, the
impression that we get from the U.S. media
or the people who would watch this is that
it's a dictatorship, it's an authoritarian
regime, it's a brutal authoritarian regime,
there is nothing that you can do.
And in fact, I found that in one case, or
actually in a couple of cases, where I was
writing for an elite American publications,
and I used the word "opposition," and the
editor turned it into "dissidents."
Because I was explained, opposition is when
there is democracy, and dissidents is in the
regimes like the Soviet Union.
So if you could draw a little bit, explain
that.
And of course, given that, it pains me to
say it, but given that you were nearly killed
last May, clearly you believe and you hope
in what you're doing.
You would not be doing otherwise.
So could you explain to us what is the state
of the Russian opposition?
What are the venues even available to it?
And secondly why are you pursuing this road?
Vladimir: Well, I think it's a very important
distinction that you made between opposition
and the dissident movement and, in fact, Boris
Nemtsov said not a long time before his death,
before he was killed, that he no longer considers
himself an opposition leader but a dissident
leader because, precisely what you said, the
opposition usually sits in Parliament.
In Russia, the opposition sits in prisons,
or more often, unfortunately, in the cemeteries
and that is a fact of life.
But I think what keeps us going is a very
simple fact, and I can speak certainly for
myself, and I'm sure for many of my friends
and colleagues.
Russia is my country.
I believe in it.
I believe in its future.
And I think the current regime is driving
it into a dead end politically, economically,
in terms of the state of society, in terms
of its relations with the outside world.
And I know there are millions of my compatriots,
millions of people in Russia, even today,
even despite everything that's happening who
also believe in a different future for Russia.
In a future based on respect for dignity and
human rights, and democracy, and the rule
of law, in political freedom, in good relations
with our neighbors and the outside world at
large.
And these people have no political voice,
they have no political representation, but
I think they offer the best hope for the future
development of Russia, and we have to do all
we can to give them this political voice,
and to support them, and to present this alternative,
to present this different vision for our country's
development.
Sure, it's a very dangerous vocation to be
in opposition to Putin's regime, and we've
seen many confirmation of this.
Soviet dissidents used to have this phrase,
"The night is darkest before the dawn."
And this past year has been, I think, especially
dark with the assassination of Boris, with
what happened to me, the attempted murder,
and with many more jailings, and many more
cases of oppression against those who disagree
with the Kremlin, and many more threats that
continue to be issued.
So it has been a very dark year.
But I believe that the night is darkest before
the dawn, and I still believe that the values
of freedom and justice will prevail in Russia.
I believe that that day will come, and I believe
that it is our moral duty, and my moral duty,
to do everything we can to bring that day
just a little bit closer.
Leon: In practical terms, as I mentioned to
you before we started, I see your name popping
up in various interviews and one of them talked
about Open Russia, the organization that you
represent, extending its offers of expertise
and funding.
Could you give us an insight of how do you
do it, how does that happen, and what hope
there is for this?
Vladimir: Sure.
Well, we know perfectly well that elections
in Putin's Russia are not real elections,
that they just serve as a ritual held once
every five or six years depending on Parliament
or President to formalize the regime's hold
on power.
The opposition is, in most cases, not allowed
to contest the elections, or in the rare cases
when it is, it is suppressed and the vast
administrative resources are used against
it.
However, we believe that boycotts do not work.
We believe that we can use even this watered-down
and sham electoral process that exists today
in order to try to get our message across,
our message based on democracy and rule of
law and European values to as many people
as we can.
And also, as importantly, I think, to help
those opposition candidates, especially young
political activists, to gain some political
experience by participating in these campaigns,
to gain some name recognitions, and to gain
some reputation for themselves.
And this is why we, the Open Russia Movement,
are planning to support 15 to 20 candidates
for the State Duma, for the Law House of the
Russian Parliament in the upcoming Duma election,
or so-called election, by offering them, as
you said, informational, legal, PR support,
infrastructural support for their campaigns
by making our experts, and our specialists
available for them, to help them gain this
experience and gain their name in this fight.
And this is what we'll be doing, and we've
tried already, in fact, last year, in 2015,
in two different cases.
One was the municipal election in St. Petersburg,
and the other one was the regional election
in Novosibirsk.
We had in both cases a candidate whom Open
Russia was backing, and in both cases our
candidate came in second, was even officially
more than 20% of the vote.
And so another important goal is to show that
however much the Kremlin likes to pretend
that the democratic opposition has 1% or 2%
support in Russia, this is simply not true
even in the current repressive conditions.
And I'm hopeful that we're going to show this
again, this time on a national level in September
of this year during the State Duma elections.
And, of course, there will also come a day,
and I think personally that it's not going
to be that long away, when there'll be a real
election in Russia.
And I think we have to start preparing for
it now and to start getting the people ready
and prepared for it, and start helping people
gain this experience that they will use when
the real election comes, and this is what
we're going to be doing starting this year.
Leon: Thank you very much, Volodya.
This is a good note to end.
Thank you very much.
Vladimir: Thank you very much.
Happy to do this.